yeah denmark like you
you've been around some of the more
legendary uh i mean obviously cypress
hill
you know exhibit serial killer [ __ ]
um dizzy and and uh shout out tj hopper
too man
i feel like every time i see disney i
usually see dj hoppa right
[Laughter]
shout out to hopper man that's sorry i
just put a new album out too uh hop in
friends part two so go support that man
that's the homie right there
but um what what i mean [ __ ] you were
just telling me like
serial killers four's coming yeah fourth
project man would
with dudes that i you know shout out
exhibit and be
real it's like i just remember wanting
to rap for be real
and just wanted to just get into i was
hoping that maybe i could get into the
studio with him and
and do some songs with him to being on
tour with them to
traveling to even tapping into uh
introducing me to the songwriting or the
or the touring and
and all of that type of stuff and then
actually being able to
loop it all the way around to being in a
group with them and
four projects later that's crazy it's
crazy well you said with uh
four like you dr dre might be touching
something on the project i mean you know
i
will we'll let that unfold when it when
it unfolds but
uh i'll tell you this maybe twisting
some knobs you know we
shout we shout we shall see but uh but
[ __ ] shout out busting rhymes he on
there shout out uh
snoop he on there and dj quicks on the
record you know and obviously dj quick
that's big
it's crazy for me you know it's like get
being on a
even just being on the record with snoop
and quick
busting i'm like damn i'm ready you know
i've seen i'm going bar to bar with bust
the bus you know if
it feels good you know one of my
favorite guest verses
or guest songs you ever you were on the
faded record with burner and be real
right
i was on uh i was on i wasn't on that
one no you were on another one on that
same album though
uh was it trump yeah
i was gonna say perks and patron xanax
and patron
yeah yo but like what are some things
that you've learned from being around be
real being around exhibit because a lot
of people don't know man exhibits like
a lot of people be like what happened to
exhibit but like exhibit is a boss
on some other [ __ ] he got his alcohol
[ __ ] and his weed [ __ ] is
out of here like yeah and he definitely
did the movies and the television
horses shot the triple x state whatever
triple x he was in
ice cube state of the union i definitely
learned a lot from him just on how to
like move through the game and just you
got to be confident
and get into it and he you know both him
and b real also taught me about
diversifying and having multiple
different things and
even dizzy